keine entwarnung laut
robert-koch-institut bleibt die korona
lage sehr ernst die kliniken melden
zunehmend engpässe etwas höhere
steuereinnahmen trotz der pandemie kann
der staat mit mehr geld rechnen als
zuletzt vorausgesagt sexualisierte
gewalt gegen kinder in münster beginnt
ein prozess gegen vier männer und eine
frau
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend schön dass
sie dabei sind wie auch norbert lehmann
für den sportlichen wunder von mir
der chef des robert koch-instituts
brachte es so auf den punkt wir werden
noch ein paar monate die pobacken
zusammenkneifen müssen
zwar würden die zahlen im moment etwas
langsamer steigen aber es sei noch zu
früh um zu beurteilen ob die seit zehn
tagen geltenden corona beschränkungen
tatsächlich wirken hier sind die
aktuellen virus zahlen innerhalb eines
tages werde das rp mehr als 21.000 800
neue infektionen und 215 neue todesfälle
immer mehr krankenhäuser in deutschland
bekommen probleme auch weil immer mehr
personal erkrankt oder in quarantäne
muss julia schröter berichtet seine
wichtigste botschaft nennt der chef des
robert koch-instituts zuerst die korona
lage in deutschland ist weiterhin sehr
ernst
doch er weckt auch hoffnungen was mich
vorsichtig optimistisch stimmt ist die
tatsache dass die fallzahlen seit
einigen tagen etwas weniger stark
zunehmen
die kurve geht also etwas weniger steil
nach oben sie flacht sich ab
in der darstellung des 7 tagesschnitt
ist das sichtbar ob das eine stabile
entwicklung ist darüber kann das rk ii
noch nichts sagen
auch ist bislang nicht ganz klar warum
genau sich der anstieg abschwächt das
kann daran liegen dass die strengeren
maßnahmen beginnen zu wirken
das wissen wir aber noch nicht genau das
kann auch mit verursacht seien dadurch
dass die laborkapazitäten langsam
ausgeschöpft sind
das heißt weil labore überlastet sind
und dass engpässe beim material etwa
chemikalien gibt bekommt nicht mehr
jeder bei verdacht einen test die
dunkelziffer wird wohl steigen
wir haben natürlich das reale geschehen
eigentlich nie vollkommen abbilden
können trotzdem geht es uns im vergleich
zu vielen anderen ländern immer noch
deutlich besser wir können deutlich mehr
in der breite testen als andere
das ist ein kompromiss mit dem man
tatsächlich lernen muss umzugehen
ich denke aber er ist vertretbar
unzweifelhaft klarheit besteht dagegen
bei der zahl der intensivpatienten
und die ist in den letzten wochen stark
gestiegen inzwischen über das niveau vom
frühjahr gestern brauchten 3127 cupid 19
patienten ein intensiv bett dieser
anstieg ist besonders dramatisch weil
gleichzeitig immer mehr kliniken mit
engpässen kämpfen 46 prozent melden
inzwischen nur eingeschränkte oder sogar
keine verfügbarkeit ihres intensiv
bereichs doppelt so viele wie noch vor
vier wochen
häufigster grund ist personalmangel denn
mit steigenden fallzahlen infizieren
sich auch immer öfter pflegerinnen und
pfleger für fragen nach bei unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten in berlin theo
koll müssen wir uns auf relativ einsame
weihnachten einstellen
zumindest auf weihnachten im engeren
familienkreis der gesundheitsminister
war da heute sogar längerfristig
deutlich feiern mit mehr als 10 bis 15
personen sieht er für den gesamten
winter nicht mehr
denn trotz der einschränkenden maßnahmen
klettern ja die neuinfektionen auf
rekordniveau wenn auch wie wir eben
gehört bei abgeflachtem anstieg es wird
immer klarer dass die politisch
verantwortlichen hier durch relativ
dichten november nebel steuern müssen
und der ursprünglich vermittelte
eindruck dass der shutdown auf november
beschränkt sei der wird mittlerweile als
fehler angesehen vielleicht hat sich die
kanzlerin auch deshalb heute geweigert
zuzusagen dass die gastronomie am ersten
dezember wieder öffnen darf der lange
infektions vorlauf und der zeitversatz
bei allen corona daten der bedeutet für
die politik vielleicht so sehr wie noch
nie ein fahren auf sicht und das bei
extrem schlechter sicht dankeschön für
diese einschätzung theo koll aus berlin
wie erlebt eine intensiv
krankenschwester die situation und wie
ist die lage genau in den krankenhäusern
dazu senden wir einen live stream um
halb neun in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kanälen die korona
pandemie lässt auch die steuereinnahmen
von bund ländern und kommunen schrumpfen
das ist längst klar
allerdings wird es wohl weniger schlimm
als noch im september erwartet davon
geht zumindest die aktuelle
steuerschätzung aus patricia wiedemeier
hat details anders als bei der letzten
steuerschätzung gab sich der
finanzminister heute optimistisch die
einnahmen sind höher als erwartet die
wirtschaft legte im dritten quartal um
über acht prozent zu wir sehen dass wir
durch diese krise durchkommen können
dass wir es möglich machen dass arbeit
und beschäftigung erhalten bleiben etwas
was in diesen schwierigen zeiten
vielleicht auch ein licht ist im
november
und der ist trübe allerdings der blick
nach vorne geht in die sonne
der arbeitskreis steuerschätzung ging
doch im september davon aus dass nach
einnahmen von 799 milliarden euro im
letzten jahr
in diesem jahr nur rund 717 anfallen
also 81 milliarden weniger
jetzt wurden diese zahlen korrigiert auf
728 also 71 milliarden weniger als im
letzten jahr
scholz verteidigte alle corona maßnahmen
die hilfs politik der regierung wirke
ganz anders sieht das die opposition und
der städtetag
wir sollten die ergebnisse von heute
nicht schönreden und werden im nächsten
jahr gut neun milliarden euro fehlen
wenn man weiß dass unsere planungen
unsere investitionsplanungen auf diesen
prognosen beruhen dann sieht man dass
wir für das nächste jahr investitionen
zurückfahren müssen selbst wenn wir
jetzt konjunkturell besser dastehen als
befürchtet werden die steuereinnahmen
nicht ausreichend um die krisenkosten zu
bewältigen
mehr geld braucht der staat auch für die
sogenannten november hilfen zb für
firmen und vereine die wegen der korona
maßnahmen schließen mussten mehr als
zehn milliarden euro
wirtschaftsminister altmaier kündigte an
ab der letzten novemberwoche könnten
entsprechende anträge online
gestellt werden wir werden
abschlagszahlungen noch im november
auszahlen
das ist deshalb wichtig damit die
betroffenen eine klare perspektive haben
die endgültigen beträge auf euro und
cent wird man in vielen fällen erst
ermitteln können einige wochen später
offen bleibt jedoch was die
ausgleichszahlung insgesamt kosten
werden und ob die steuereinnahmen
wirklich ansteigen alles abhängig davon
wie lange die korona pandemie noch
anhält
in die usa
das land ist nach wie vor am schlimmsten
von der pandemie betroffen
und während sich präsident donald trump
weiterhin weigert die amtsübergabe an
joe biden vorzubereiten wird die korona
lage dort immer schlimmer innerhalb
eines tages haben sich mehr als 143.000
menschen angesteckt wieder ein neuer
höchstwert
insgesamt zählen die usa seit beginn der
pandemie 10,4 millionen corona fälle
britta jäger kelly mika unternimmt erste
gehversuche
nachdem ihre kugel infektion die
36-jährige aus minnesota an die lungen
maschine und ins koma gebracht hatte ich
wusste ich heiko witt vom ersten moment
an hatte ich symptome dann wurde es
immer schlimmer und schlimmer in
amerikas krankenhäusern füllen sich die
intensivbetten und zwar rasant seit
einer woche liegt die zahl der täglichen
neuinfektionen bei mehr als 100.000
besonders schlimm ist es in el paso
texas hier stehen die kühlwagen zur
aufbewahrung von leichen bereit jeder
dreißigste bewohner ist an cupid
erkrankt der bundesstaat hat als erster
die marke von insgesamt einer million
corona fälle erreicht auch in utah gibt
es immer mehr patienten aber nicht mehr
personal
es lassen sich noch betten finden der
schwierige teil ist das personal wir
haben nicht genug mitarbeiter um die
enorm gestiegene zahl an patienten zu
versorgen
weit mehr als 1000 erkrankte sterben in
den usa zurzeit pro tag dennoch glauben
experten dass mediziner mit größeren
know-how in der behandlung
so wird nunmehr menschenleben retten
können wie das von kelly mika ich sage
trägt eine maske ich bin fast daran
gestorben es ist ernster als die leute
denken
überall im land verschärfen
bundesstaaten nun die maßnahmen von
masten pflicht auch in innenräumen bis
restaurant und bar schließungen um die
kontrolle nicht noch weiter zu verlieren
die gesundheitsbehörde de warnt vor
einer mutierten versionen des corona
virus die vor allem bei pelztieren
vorkommt es könne sich schnell
ausbreiten
besonders betroffen ist dänemark dort
wurde die virusvariante bereits auf
menschen übertragen
mehr als 200 personen haben sich bislang
angesteckt die dänische regierung
ordnete an alle etwa 17 millionen zucht
nerze zu töten
allerdings hat sie dafür keine
rechtliche grundlage einer hebestreit
berichtet für farmer amateuren sind sind
es schwere tage
er ist eine von 1100 dänischen märz
züchtern und muss mit ansehen wie seine
tiere geschlachtet werden die
wertvollsten wille erstmal verschoben
wie die beste team die besten tiere
behalten wir bis zuletzt hoffen auf ein
wunder das geht mir arge ball die
nerzfarm als brutstätten für mutierte
viren gelten und sich bereits menschen
angesteckt haben dürfen die bewohner
nordjütland jetzt nicht mehr verlassen
soweit die dänischen behörden mitgeteilt
haben es keine anzeichen dass das
mutierte virus ansteckender geworden sei
oder schlimmere verläufe verursacht die
größte sorge ist dass die mutation die
behandlung oder die wirksamkeit von
impfstoffen beeinflusst aber das ist
noch nicht wissenschaftlich geklärt
dänemarks regierung gerät in
erklärungsnot sie hat die tötung aller
nerze veranlasst obwohl sie nur tiere in
regierungen beseitigen lassen darf in
denen das virus aufgetreten ist statt
rechtzeitig eine entsprechende
gesetzliche regelung zu beschließen hat
die regierung monatelang zugesehen wie
sich immer mehr nerz bestände mit dem
virus infiziert haben keinen kurven
ich habe zu beginn der ko mit 19 krise
gesagt dass wir fehler machen und nun
haben wir einen fehler gemacht und mir
leid ändert aber nichts an unserem plan
es geht hier um die gesundheit und so
wickelt dänemark die weltweit größte
nerze produktion ab ohne dass die frage
geklärt ist wie die farmer entschädigt
werden es geht um umgerechnet über eine
milliarde euro vor der küste libyens
sind mindestens 74 menschen ertrunken
das teilten die vereinten nationen mit
47 überlebende seien gerettet und an
land gebracht worden
in diesem jahr sind schon mindestens 900
migranten ums leben gekommen bei dem
versuch über das mittelmeer nach europa
zu gelangen
ende 2022 geht das letzte deutsche
atomkraftwerk vom netz die
energiekonzerne bekommen einen
finanziellen ausgleich dafür dass sie
früher abschalten
das entsprechende gesetz hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht aber heute
gekippt wegen verfahrensfehlern
zudem seien die ausgleichszahlungen für
die unternehmen teilweise und zumutbar
jetzt muss die bundesregierung noch mal
ran die bundesanwaltschaft hat anklage
gegen zwölf mutmaßliche rechts
terroristen erhoben die gruppe soll
attentate auf spitzenpolitiker sowie
angriffe auf moscheen geplant haben
gegen die sogenannte gruppe es hatte es
im februar eine razzia gegeben dabei
wurden in mehreren bundesländern
wohnungen durchsucht das ziel der gruppe
soll es gewesen sein
bürgerkriegsähnliche zustände
herbeizuführen
ein mann der mutmaßlich seinen stiefsohn
vergewaltigt und dazu auch andere männer
einlädt seine mutter die dafür ihre
gartenlaube zur verfügung stellt
ermittler die von unfassbaren bildern
und videos berichten in münster begann
heute der prozess vier männer und eine
frau stehen vor gericht
ariane güdel berichtet der
hauptangeklagte im missbrauchsfall
münster ist ein 27-jähriger it-techniker
zu seinen mutmaßlichen mittätern gehören
drei weitere männer und seine 45 jährige
mutter einer der tatorte eine
gartenlaube am stadtrand von münster die
opfer hier fünf und
jahre alt den fünf angeklagten wird
schwerer sexueller missbrauch
vergewaltigung und gefährliche
körperverletzung vorgeworfen die männer
sollen sich im internet kennengelernt
und sich nur getroffen haben um die
kinder gemeinsam zu missbrauchen
die mutter des haupttäters hat in einem
kindergarten gearbeitet und soll ihren
sohn gedeckt haben die mutter soll
eigentümerin der gartenlaube gewesen
sein und diese gartenlaube den männern
überlassen haben über das wochenende
jedenfalls in dem wissen dass die männer
dort die beiden kinder schwer sexuell
missbrauchen
die angeklagten haben ihre taten gefilmt
experten konnten 30 stunden lange
aufnahmen von einer bereits gelöschten
festplatte wieder herstellen ein
großteil konnte noch nicht ausgewertet
werden wir gehen von einer möglichen
brutto daten speichern von 1200 terabyte
aus oder 1,2 pa weiter sind unfassbare
datenmengen
dieser und andere missbrauchsfälle haben
die politik aufgeschreckt die nordrhein
westfälische landesregierung hat eine
neue anlaufstelle für prävention
eingerichtet weil sie in sexuellen
dingen weitestgehend nicht sprechen sind
wir erwachsenen müssen lernen über
sexuelle dinge zu sprechen und auch
kindern die erlaubnis zu geben dies zu
tun
und wenn wir diesbezüglich
ansprechbarkeit signalisieren erhöhen
wir die chance dass sich mädchen und
jungen an vertrauen
der prozess findet zum schutz der opfer
ohne öffentlichkeit statt
heute vor 65 jahren begann die
geschichte der bundeswehr die ersten 101
soldaten erhielten damals ihre
ernennungsurkunden ohne große zeremonie
und auch das jubiläum heute viel corona
bedingt klein aus im garten von schloss
bellevue legten neuen soldaten und
soldatinnen ihr gelöbnis ab
stellvertretend für alle rekruten im
land bundespräsident steinmeier warnte
vor einem freundlichen desinteresse
gesellschaft und armee dürften sich
niemals fremd werden
schon wieder hat ein taifun die
philippinen getroffen wo ist der fünfte
wirbelsturm innerhalb nur eines monats
mit windböen von mehr als 250 kilometern
pro stunde zog er über die hauptinsel
große teile wurden verwüstet und
überschwemmt häuser versanken teils
völlig in den schlammigen fluten
hunderte bewohner konnten sich nur noch
auf die dächer retten
mindestens elf menschen kamen ums leben
nach all den düsteren nachrichten
norbert liegt es jetzt an der sendung
noch einen aufwind nach oben zu geben
mit der fußball nationalmannschaft ja
immerhin ein 1 0-sieg ist ja auch schon
was positives gestern abend im testspiel
gegen tschechien aber am samstag da
wird's ernst denn dann geht's in der
nations league gegen die ukraine
und da setzt trainer joachim löw auf
sein top team die fußball stars die sind
heute in leipzig eingetroffen
seit heute mittag ist die mannschaft
wieder vollzählig neben den bayern sind
zum beispiel auch groß und werner
eingetroffen die zeit der experimente
geht zu ende
was man gegen ukraine und spanien
eigentlich in der besetzung spielen weil
ein spielen ist natürlich jetzt schon
einmal ein wichtiges thema klar die
hoffnungsvolle zweite reihe hat gestern
gegen tschechien zumindest eine halbzeit
lang bewiesen dass mit ihr zu rechnen
sein wird das einzige tor zum 1 0
siegtreffer gelang luca waldschmidt von
benfica lissabon
schon nach 13 minuten auch kapitän
manuel neuer ist inzwischen in leipzig
angekommen und wird morgen ins tor
zurückkehren wo ihn kevin trapp gestern
fehlerfrei vertreten hat in leipzig
haben sie schon seit der
wiedervereinigung nicht mehr verloren
na dann von dem lob das ist die härteste
einhandsegler regatta der welt einmal um
den globus 24.000 seemeilen nonstop 70
tage sind dafür angepeilt und nur eine
frau oder ein mann an bord statue am
sonntag jeder tag und jede nacht eine
neue herausforderung
schon die ersten vier tage hatten es in
sich
nach flaute und einer frühen sturmfront
mit bis zu 53 knoten verlieren die
segler jetzt zwei tage bei der umfahrung
des tropensturms liter als erster
deutscher segler dabei liegt boris
herrmann mit seiner yacht im mittelfeld
er zögerte aus angst bei fünf meter
hohen wellen zu schnell zu werden hatte
dadurch aber lediglich den riss einer
leine zu beklagen
trotzdem ärgert er sich
ich habe den wind verloren die führenden
sind zwischen 15 und 30 meilen vor mir
und die haben wahrscheinlich sind
riskanter fahren die boote sind zwar
schneller vermelden jedoch größere
schäden in führung liegt zur zeit der
brite und favorit alex thomson
da muss man für geboren sein ende gar
noch ungefähr sind sie dann mal im ziel
ankommen hat den kann es völlig wurscht
sein welche einschränkungen über
weihnachten gelten
es ist mehr wind mehr sonne und etwas
regen
das ist die kurzfassung mehr zum wetter
hat gleich katja hornuf das heute
journal um viertel vor zehn mit claus
kleber wir danken für interesse wünschen
ihnen einen friedlichen und heiteren
abend und sagen tschüss bis morgen wenn
sie mir
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren das
dauer grau sind wir mehr und mehr los
und das liegt an verschiedenen tiefs die
kleine kaltfront von tief petra brachte
uns schon heute wolken wind und etwas
regen und schauen sie mir hier auf diese
wunderschöne wolken spirale von dem tief
quentin die sich da südlich von island
ein kringel und auch dieses tief bringt
uns einige wolken und etwas regen am
wochenende jetzt in der nacht regnete es
an den küsten von nord- und ostsee sonst
ist es häufig nur locker bewölkt mitte
und im süden bildet sich auch mal liebe
in den mittelgebirgen aber auch am
alpenrand sinken die temperaturen auf 3
bis 0 grad dort droht also bodenfrost
sonst bleibt die nacht bei 8 bis 4 grad
milder
morgen erwarten uns höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 10 und 13 grad im südwesten am
rhein und westlich davon wird es mit 14
bis 17 grad schon deutlich milder
am vormittag hält sich noch ein bisschen
niebel an der donau sonst aber wird das
ein sehr freundlicher start in den
freitag dann aber kommen am nachmittag
von westen dichte wolken heran
die bringen schon im ersten regen mit
bei südwesten und etwas regen fällt auch
noch am wochenende aber bevor es am
sonntagnachmittag von besten kräftig
geregnet steigen die temperaturen bis 20
grad
schönen abend noch